Within the framework of the visit of the
President of the European Commission Úrsula
Fonderlayen,
the
President of the Argentine Nation
Dr. Alberto Fernández and the
President of the European Commission Úrsula
Fonderlayer have entered the white room of this government house.
Also present are members of both committees,
special guests, ladies and gentlemen,
welcome. The
signing of the memorandum of understanding
for a strategic association on
sustainable value chains of
raw materials between the Argentine Republic and the
European Union will be followed by
the President of the
Argentine nation Dr. Alberto Fernández and the
president of the European Commission
Úrsula founderlayen
both leaders
then proceed to the exchange of respective folders
after the act of signing the
memorandum of understanding between both
nations and with the purpose of communicating
the strategic guidelines of the
joint declaration  and according to the
previously signed agreement, a press conference will be held by
both
leaders. Immediately afterwards,
the president of the
Argentine nation, Dr. Alberto Fernández, makes use of the floor.
Good morning to all,
I want to start
by welcoming Mrs.
President of the European Commission,
we have had the opportunity to speak
many times over the years, but for
me it is a great joy to receive her here
in my homeland in Argentina
on a tour that began in Brazil and
continues throughout our country, a great joy
to have her with us.  We have been able to
talk about the problems that
link Argentina with Europe
on a timely basis
and
the issues that we have pending, such as
Mercosur and the European Union, we
all know that there was a principle of
agreement
signed a few years ago
that later we asked for a
review of that agreement because
we understood  that it did not fully meet
the
interests of the region. I am
talking about the European Union framework agreement.
For this reason, we ask
to review the text of the agreement.
From Mercosur, we have worked all
this time together with the other
member countries of Mercosur to present to
the European Union the requirements that
the Zuraza framework
that basically has the purpose
of ending the imbalances or
asymmetries that exist objectively
between both economies and that we
need to
clarify in order to preserve the
proper development of our region.
We definitely want
an agreement with the European Union, but one that
balances
the economies
of  each one of the regions and that takes
into account these asymmetries because
otherwise what we
envision at the beginning could happen, which is an
agreement that
clearly benefits the European Union and does not
benefit so much to say nothing of harming
Mercosur,
the truth is that  I must say that
the talk with
the president of the
European Commission was very fruitful because we were also able to discuss
other projects that Argentina has
within Mercosur and that is clearly
from what I heard they are of interest to the
European Union, fundamentally those
that have to do with the
energy development the possibility of Europe
becoming more actively involved in the
production of lithium
in adding value to the production of
liquid through the production of
batteries in the exploitation of copper in
the exploitation of green hydrogen in
the implementation of
liquefaction plants  gas
all the energy issues that
Europe needs and that Argentina and
Mercosur in general can really be a supplier
for me this meeting has been a pleasure what
I see is that we have a
much more common perspective than what we
initially thought we
both thought  Europe and Latin America
and the South framework The word escapes me
Latin America and the Mercosur and Argentina
punctually we have a look as a
on the challenges that the world faces
on the need to make
common cause in the corrections of
climate change of the climate crisis
that the world suffers and
I believe that Europe is
an extraordinary partner for Argentina
Europe is, like the European Union, the largest
foreign investor that Argentina has and
therefore I believe that we must deepen that
bond.
So, dear president,
welcome to Argentina, enjoy
our homeland
enjoy our our meat our
roast our beauties as a
country
and
the best of your stay for him in the
homeland Thank you very much then
we will listen to the words of the
president of the European Commission Úrsula
fonderlayen
in Argentina
argentinations between Argentina
Argentina Argentina
Argentina
[Music]
Once the words
of the President of the
European Commission have finished, we are going to give way. So, yes to
the questions planned for this
instance, first of all the
representative of the Efe agency will do it.
Hello, I am Verónica from the F agency, for
Ursula Van Der,
regarding  of the mercosur agreement European Union
if you still expect it to close this year
since the Argentine president recently
made his reservations and then
the president of Brazil also made a
reservation about the conditions that
the European Union demanded of him
Argentina
[Music]
then he
will formulate I can add something  Because that
's where it was understood,
what I said was understood in a different way, we
have a concern that it
dates from the year
18 when 19 was signed when the
agreement was signed, that these are observations that we
made public,
these observations do not mean that
we are not interested in having
a  agreement with the European Union we are
very interested in having an agreement with the
European Union we believe that the
agreement European Union Latin America
generates an axis of economic development
that in a world that tends to
become bipolar once again is
very important in geopolitical terms with what  which
I very much celebrate the meeting that we just
had because for the first time
we have been able to speak clearly about what
are the problems that we see
What are the concerns that
we have and I
found in the president absolute
receptivity about what was raised with
which
I would be very happy Yes  before the
end of the year we can sign that
political agreement and having
agreed on the concerns that
I have about these asymmetries that I mentioned
new regulations that
the European Union has issued in environmental matters and that in
some way affect the initial agreement
but in no way can  interpreting
what I said as not being in tune
with the president. That is why I want to
clarify it. Because if someone understood it
that way, this module should not be understood, I
just wanted to make it clear how
history is that we can definitely
transform into this work
as in Argentina  It is going to present
its partners to Mercosur
three specific issues that have to do
with the European Union agreement to
unlock the agreement, not to block the
agreement, and we are going to send these three points
to the European Union
to move forward,
we believe  in the European Union
Mercosur agreement, but as I told the
president,
that calls for both parties to
gain from the mutual
benefit of the agreement, but please, if
someone interpreted my words as
objections to the agreement, do not take it that
way
well for  to continue the series of
questions then
the representative of radio province will ask the following question,
what's up president, how are you doing?
with the countryside with this
agricultural production Argentina on the other
hand the times in Argentina as they are
You said well that you also want to
reach an agreement before the end of the year
what would be the main obstacles
in that sense Let's say if you have to
raise raise at a regional level  there are
some issues as you said and that is
precisely going to take
time and on the other hand if there was a
proposal around, for example, good
raw materials such as lithium, you
already said the same as industrialization in
Argentina that  there is added value that does not
leave Argentina that way and if
also in that sense there is also the
possibility of financing by
the European Union for other
industries also not
the president I think she has been very clear
about an investment plan for the
European Union in Mercosur,
where the energy issue and
clean energy, renewable energy is a
central issue and where Argentina is clearly envisioned
as having great
potential for the future.
The problems we initially had
were problems
that some European presidents
raised, for example.  President
Macron saw the
clearing of the Amazon with concern, but that
concern that President
Macron had was also felt by me, I
saw with great concern that the
government of President Bolsonaro
is clearing the Amazon because the
truth is that this idea
will determine the jungles and  using the
forests to sow soybeans
is a remedy that generates disease if
irony may be allowed, therefore
this was a crucial point for which
progress could not be made now thanks to God
the arrival of President Lula Brazil
that problem is being
has disappeared  because President
Lula does not participate in these policies and, on the
contrary, it is through him and
Marina Silva that they are great promoters of
caring for the environment.
So that initial problem
we had with the European Union has
disappeared, now
other problems have appeared that have to do with
with the protectionism of some
European countries to
agricultural and livestock production and a second
problem that is a green pact that
Europe signs to improve the conditions
of European development cleaner development
but that inevitably
affect the agreement. Those are the things
we have  What to talk about These are the
issues that we can discuss and what is it
that I celebrate that we have been able to discuss all this that I am telling you
face to face with the president, looking into each other's
eyes, raising our concern
and seeing the will of everyone to want to
reach  to an agreement with the European Union
and what I feel is that the obstacles
lie with us and in Europe to begin to
remove them and that it is not so difficult to
remove them if the
political will of which the president speaks
as a first step exists  our part
the political will exists what is it
that we ask for a balanced agreement an
agreement where we all win
Thank you life to close this round of
questions
the
representative of the coast of Santa Fe will ask the following question
Good afternoon president of the
European commission welcome to the Republic
Argentina Good afternoon, President of
our country, I told the official who is
visiting us that a month ago I had
the opportunity to be five
kilometers from the border between Ukraine
and Russia and I saw how, despite the passage of
time, the hostilities in the theater of
operations continue  And for his part,
President Zelensky demands a
larger shipment of weapons from his Western allies.
I take the opportunity
to talk with you to
ask you precisely, taking the
speech of the detractors of the
strategy that the West is taking
who maintain that the European Union is
NATO  and its allies, by handing over
weapons to Ukraine, what they are doing
is ensuring that
this armed conflict in which
Ukraine defends itself against the
Russian military invasion is sustained over time, so
I want to ask you what you respond to that
position and if it is possible
to evaluate another  way to defend a country
like Ukraine that is defending an
invasion like the one we are mentioning,
what is it and in that framework, if
there is an alternative, such as
the Mercosur countries, thank you and you
pray is concert
It is not 16
[  Music]
International
Now
What's stop Fighting
the words
stops defending
and running
We have seen age Million people cleans
well
ladies and gentlemen then in this
way and in the framework of the visit to the
Argentine Republic of the
president of the European commission Úrsula
Thunder Legend  We conclude
this act to everyone Thank you very much
for your presence have an
excellent day and see you always